Eric hey what's up dude we have a vault
boy wired controller and supposedly
these are no longer no longer in stores
yep you could only buy it i think that
one week during with us is like sale of
all these fallout products currently is
not available anymore it was 59 99 this
is actually danny's we're gonna unbox it
for him so i want you get into it let's
do it so yes it is a wired controller i
am told to hear some instructions we'll
get to that later 10 feet of pure
awesome miss us be right there boom boom
and then we have the controller itself
alright so looks like we got a blue and
yellow ball boy scheme there very nice
it's got a nice kind of rubber grip all
around here this is a plastic you got
sticks these aren't eyes like concave as
the other controllers yeah the ones I
wasn't that big of a fan of it
personally myself what you said they
felt pretty good so yeah they feel
pretty good I mean my you know my thumbs
aren't really moving like sometimes you
have to like readjusts you know but like
it feels pretty good triggers are great
but the kicker here is you got this
volume button here which does three
things got three functions one if you
are voice chatting no longer do you need
this guy for for your voice chat online
play we're talking your buddies you push
this once to mute yourself you hold it
and push up and down to just your game
volume you hold it as well to go left
and right to balance between the game
audio and your chat audio so that's
actually a pretty sweet function no
longer do you have to kind of go into
the menu of the xbox during a game you
can do it on the fly cool all right
that's the controller 12 your fallout
news you go to gamespot com
you